I am a coward.
How can I abandon someone
who is about to die?
I can download you
into my memory archives,
and we can operate in a joined mode.
-I'll navigate.
-Do you want me to follow an amateur?
We are approaching a level one storm.
We need to go down.
Down?
It's a guess, but yes.
Jump across the next crevice!
The storm is behind me.
Estimated level three!
The body will stand. Let's go!
Don't be ridiculous!
The Orichalt ore is straight ahead!
Come on!
You have some guts!
Dead end?!
The only thing you're good at
is giving orders!
This is...
the size, the sparkle...
I've never seen an Orichalt like this.
How much time is left
before the storm hits?
Probably two to three minutes.
I'll get it.
What?!
Something is interfering
with the consciousness signal.
My archives are--
What?
What is that?
Here it comes!
Rick, leave!
The biggest storm is approaching!
How can we leave Ido and Maya?
You will get hit, too!
Damn!
Come on, come on!
Ido, this is crazy!
What are you talking about?
It was your idea from the start.
This is completely different!
This is too much!
Hey, you.
Yes, sir?
Did you say your name was Maya?
You did well.
You-- You are welcome.